yes I'm naturally I think the organizers
for giving the opportunity to talk about
the kinds of questions that my lab is in
particularly this actually comes from
the collaboration I've had with Craig
Gilman who unfortunately died last year
this collaboration has lasted several
decades and we've concentrated on trying
to come up with new ideas for
relationships with others in the books I
don't have time to go into very much
detail I won't have a few examples of
experiments aimed at testing some of
these questions but most of the talk is
going to be directed at identifying what
we think are interesting questions and
some speculations a lot really a lot of
data
I also want to indicate that much of
what we're doing them involves a
collaboration colleague of JSON the
basics living-circuitry explain how we
divide into two types we call the first
and five order and this has components
or cortical processing I'm going to
switch gears quite fairly dramatically
and consider what the role of the
driving inputs the thalamus is by
driving inputs the thalamus we mean the
inputs that carry the information
relate to cortex for instance of the
retinal imparts a lot of genetic and
ripples and how they might be related to
prints copies and I want to mention now
that this is going to be very
speculative and you think oh anybody
just want to turn the mic
here mean oh yeah my goal here is not
necessarily to get to agree with me that
frankly that doesn't matter to me so
much as it is to make sure that or try
to get across ideas that we think need
to be addressed that have been pretty
much ignored up till now and aligned
with some of these speculations okay so
this is a cartoon view of the human
thalamus this would be the back to the
front of the left thalamus these shown
in color here represent the relay nuclei
these contain cells that project the
cortex each projects to one or a small
number of cortical areas the thalamic
nuclei reticular nucleus who actually
would sit flush against the lateral
surface that's pulled away and cut away
so you can see the relay nuclei these
this nucleus contains GABAergic
inhibitory neurons that don't project
the cortex instead they innervate relay
cells and provide powerful number in
addition they're two points I want to
emphasize is that as far as we know all
cortical areas receive the polemic input
and virtually all information reaching
cortex must pass through thalamus there
are some exceptions to this but this
means that the thalamus is a very
strategic location for information flow
and if information doesn't get through
thalamus cortex what we see but you
won't be consciously aware of it you
want perceive it and we think this is an
the thalamus plays a very important role
in intention I'm going to draw attention
to two thalamic nuclei that are involved
in visual relays the lateral geniculate
nucleus of-- obviously release retinol
information and this is a monkey brain
that with a computer assist has been
flattened out this is v1 that gets the
input from the lateral geniculate
nucleus the pulvinar which is the
largest relay in the thalamus inter base
all of the extra strike visual areas
nearly the back half of cortex so we
think of this as a visual relay also and
the size of the pulvinar is about 30 to
50 times larger than the LGN by volume
get back to the size difference later so
using the LG m as an exemplar of
thalamic circuitry there we have the
relay from retina to relay cell up to
middle layers of cortex this is layer
four five and six this these axons use
glutamate is their neurotransmitter
we have local gabbard's you can put from
the thalamic reticular nucleus and local
inter neurons that are GABAergic we have
a feedback from layer six it's also
glutamatergic and finally we have inputs
from the brainstem brain stem reticular
formation that bring classic module
victory inputs to thousands cholinergic
nor hundred nerds and so on and what
emphasis emphasize that these relay
cells get to glutamatergic inputs but
they're quite different functionally
Ferran Briggs and after lunch we'll talk
a lot more about this feedback but we
think of the retinal input is the
driving input and this is providing a a
modular tori function much like
cholinergic input to these relay cells
the difference being that the classic
modulators are very diffusely organized
but glutamatergic modulation provides
the only pathways that have a high
degree of typography to give you
modulation which is needed for such
things as spatial attention other
phenomics nuclei are organized pretty
much the same as far as a non retinal
inputs the main difference is the input
to be relayed there are differences here
to be sure but I'm going to ignore them
to the first approximation it's pretty
much the same so if we can identify the
input to be relayed we can know a lot
about a ceramic nucleus in its function
and that has been a bit of a challenge
now when the use of the idea of
different sources of driver input to
divide thalamus and the first
environment of components
there's our LGN again and here is the
pulvinar and the pulvinar has again the
same nan Madol inputs pretty much with
minor differences but the question is
what is the driving input and just like
the retinal input del GN which
terminates
you know with very large synapses on
proximal dendrites often in complex
living
glomeruli we've known for decades that
there is a similar kind of synapse on
poet ourselves the question has been was
a source of these synapses and work over
the last decade or so has made it pretty
clear that for most of thought all
pulvinar cells the driving input comes
from layer 5 of cortex itself so we have
an interesting scheme here ratha lamech
relays get a feedback from layer 6 it is
a modular Tory input but pulvinar selves
in addition to that cortical input get
another one from layer 5 it's not
organized as a feedback but in this
example as a feed-forward and these
excellents have the same property as the
Retel input LG n so the suggestion then
is that pulvinar provides a relay from
one cortical area to another we call LG
n and exemplars the first order relay
because it's a first relay of a
particular kind of information a cortex
visual in this case and pulvinar we call
a higher-order relay because it's
relaying information not from a
subcortical source but from cortex
itself between cortical areas and I
should point out that it's we think the
pulvinar relays information not just
between v1 and v2 but you can go up the
hierarchy remember how much larger
pulvinar is the Nalgene so there's
plenty of bandwidth for this we see this
division not just in the visual system
but also the somatosensory system where
the equipment of the algae on the first
order relay is vpm and VPL the posterior
medial group is the higher-order relay
and the auditory system the ventral
division of the medial genican is first
order the dorsal division is high order
and so on but one point I want to
emphasize is that while we have these
transfer lamech pathways to to connect
visual cortical areas we also have
direct connections we don't have very
many examples about five or so mostly
from the mount from the mouse but for
those examples anytime there's a direct
connection between cortical areas
there's a parallel trans lamech one and
this raises a number of questions first
how often is this parallel organization
seen or to rephrase the question how
often do our areas connected just by the
direct or the drug
Tomek pathway yeah so I have a big
memory of reading that it's a very
specific set of layer five cells yes
they're fine okay the other layer five
cells don't project subcortical II they
project other cortical areas the same
neuron that gets you for say from v1
doesn't go back to any one is there
protection up back to v1 yeah
that's an open question and we with the
quest one question of the week don't
have an answer to is whether there's
this is feed-forward there may be
feedback pathways is long this awful
that's another question we're trying to
resolve so one question again is how
common this parallel organization is a
second question is what's different in
the nature of the information between
the direct and trans limit pathways and
the third question is why bother to send
one information route through thalamus
we don't have answers to those questions
some parcel suggestions but I think
those are important questions to keep in
mind now I'm going to just show some
evidence for these trans limbic pathways
first a slice experiment that's been
published some time ago these are brain
slices in the mouse they're about a half
a millimeter thick and they're cut in a
very precise angle in this case in the
somatosensory system to preserve this
the circuit between the primary
somatosensory cortex the higher-order
Flajnik relay and the secondary area we
can't do this in the visual system for
topological reasons and I want to
emphasize that because of the angle of
the cut
we've artefactual II cut the direct
pathway so you won't see evidence for
any connection here but that's an
artifact of the slice what we're doing
is uncaging glutamate over layer 5 and
when you do that you see some activity
in thalamus but also activity in the
second cement of sensory area and it can
be fallen to the third area and I will
say since has all been published I'm not
going to show you that if the uncaging
is done in layer 6 or above layer 5 you
see no activation of the higher court
various to show that this depends on the
phenomena creel a we can put a drop of
DN q x which is an ample block or
blocking the synapse on a slice and when
you do that you completely obliterate
the responses in the higher cortical
area when you wash the DN q x-- away you
restored most of the activation in the
higher areas so what this tells us is
that this pathway is a very robust
pathway a very strong one and certainly
this is consistent with the idea that
this pathway is carrying important
information I will tell you again since
this has all been published if we cut
the slice at a different angle that
preserves the direct pathway you can see
evidence for a strong connection there
as well so we do have parallel
organization in these circuits don't uh
switch gears to talk about the evidence
for this in awake behaving animals we
use a Kree line mouse that were Korea's
provided in their five cells which
allows you to specifically target these
layer five cells particular particular
agents and the one we're interested in
these layer five cells of course er that
give rise to the to the cortical mo
cortical pathways we're using a dread
approach here designer receptors
exclusively activated by designer drugs
you can target these designer receptors
to these layer 5 cells specifically
these are modified muscarinic receptors
when you put the the inject the viral
vector into in this case v1 you get the
layer 5 cells taking up these receptors
and they're sent to the through the
entire cell including to their terminals
wherever they are the agonist for these
receptors is CMO and when CNO is placed
on these receptors or or on the cell
body you open potassium channels leading
to a strong hyper-polarization and this
will at synaptic terminals will greatly
reduce transmitter release so that's the
idea of
these experiments to show how this works
in a slice in this case in the
somatosensory system we put the dread
receptors and channelrhodopsin
both creative Pena into s1 so the
channel would often and the drug
receptors the chatter adopts and is
labeled with the green tag the dred
receptors of the red tag and you can see
that it's layer 5 cells that are taking
these up you can see their terminals the
channelrhodopsin labeled terminals and
the dred terminals in the higher-order
relay you don't seem in the first order
relay cassoulet or 5 doesn't project
there when we activate the synapse
between the layer 5 and the cell we
patched an NPO em with Kennywood ops and
you see the large inward currents with
each pulse of light when we add see a
note of a slice we get a tremendous
reduction in the synapses expected about
90% and we can repeat this experiment in
the visual system which as the system
will use in vivo same kind of experiment
the same kind of reduction in the Mayo 5
I'm sorry where are you recording
here we're recording in p om and we
patch a cell that's in this labeled area
here we're doing it in pivara okay so
the preparation we're using here is a
mouse that has the layer 5 pre line and
that is crossed to a gcamp Mouse so that
we have a calcium signal in cortical
neurons we put a window over v2 so we're
able to monitor the responses of
hundreds of cortical cells
simultaneously the animal's head fixed
on a treadmill so he's awake and
behaving and although we haven't done so
behavior yet one of the plans we hope to
fulfill is to get some more
sophisticated behavior to test some of
our ideas the animal is looking at an NS
visual stimulus in this case of drifting
grating and this is an example of what
you see these cells in v2 these are v2
cells are very selective for direction
and orientation of movement I'm just
showing four directions here we
we do 8 to 12 and you can plot in these
examples a high degree of Direction
orientation selectivity so this is a
normal v2 and this is the signal you get
that reflects their action potentials of
these cells this is the at the best
orientation and direction and again you
could plot the tuning curves so the
experiment involves putting the dred
receptor into v1 and the idea here is
that these layer 5 cells pick up the
drug receptor they not only sentence of
terminals and pulvinar but they're these
axons branch quite a bit and they're
many other targets they could
potentially affect v2 so to make sure
that we're just looking at this pathway
here we put the CNO directly in the
pulvinar which will affect only the
synapse and not other synapses of this
pathway and when we do that in many
cases we get a dramatic reduction in
responses and visual responses because
we we've blocking this pathway there's
another example some cells are not
affected they show the population
activity there's a surprisingly dramatic
effect almost all cells with some
exceptions have their responses
dramatically reduced this shows what's
happened if we put an artificial CSF
instead of the CNO as a control there's
some effect here but it's much much less
than here statistically a big difference
between these two and this just shows a
couple of examples of tuning curves
before and after well this is a surprise
to us because we didn't expect the trans
lamech pathway to be so powerful this
tells us two things this trans lemak
pathway is necessary for the responses
of mostly two cells we don't know if
it's sufficient but we can say the
reverse and while the direct v1 to v2
pathway is still present that pathway we
would conclude is not sufficient for
activation perhaps this isn't surprising
because if you knock out the thalamic
input to be one from LGN you won't get
b1 responses and maybe the case of the
flan we can put any quarter queries
what more important than then we
generally think but that's all
speculation for now okay I'm gonna
switch gears now and consider no sorry I
hate to ask this question did you do the
closet the CNF injection without friends
I'm sorry did you do the C&O injection
without friends yes they're a whole
series of excitedly I should have
emphasized this is preliminary the one
can truly done a couple of controls
looking at the because the injections
are done a later time period we're
looking at early two versus late time
period we're looking at injections
without dread we're looking at well as I
showed you us artificial CMS when we
have dreads we're there a variety of
controls we have to go through we don't
fart from completing them okay I'm gonna
switch gears and I'm gonna talk about be
friends copies and the idea is and when
there's a motor command for any kind of
behavior there has to be a copy of that
motor command sentient to an early part
of the sensory processing stream the
idea be friends coffees are very
important let me just take a few minutes
to explain me consider what happens when
you move your eyes and we move our eyes
about three to five times a second we
make these FAFSA cards physically when
you move your eyes the visual world
stimulus on your retina moves in the
opposite direction but you don't
normally experience the world moving
around as you move our eyes the world
seems stable and the reason for this is
that the motor command to move your eyes
a copy of that command is sent early in
the processing of visual information so
that it basically eliminates that eye
the the effect of the eye movement in
visual processing so the v a-- time the
next sensory stimulus comes along that's
taken into account the idea of
difference copies was appreciated as
early as the middle of the 19th century
by Helmholtz and others it was first
identified in frogs and fishes in 1950
experimentally we believe it's important
for any animal that has any
complicated behavior and it's important
for us to disambiguate changes the
environment that are caused by the
environment itself versus those changes
that are induced by our own movements
that's an important distinction to make
so the question I'm going to try to
bring up without answers but some
speculation is what is the source of the
sequence coffee and how do you make a
precise copy one of the things that we
think might be involved of branching
axons branching axons are ubiquitous in
the brain they're found all over the
place the one thing we think we know
about branching axons and mammals
warm-blooded animals is that that's the
most efficient and they're free way to
get the exactly the same message the
same pattern of action potentials down
all the branches to the targets it
doesn't mean the response is
postsynaptically you move at the same
because you would expect these synapses
to be different but if you want to copy
a message to multiple targets of
branching excellence it's a nice way to
do it the branching axons were first
emphasized by qahal he did this over 100
years ago this just shows one of his
drawings of spinal map of Africa primary
efforts coming in the spinal cord he
emphasized very strongly the fact that
every one of these Brit axons branched
one branch going to the spinal gray
matter the other branch a sending
towards the brain this is a modern
textbook view of that drawing and we
would call this branch going into the
spinal Gray as a message to the spinal
Gray
this message going up to the brain we
think of this them as a motor message
because it'll have a fairly strong
impact on motor neurons maybe not
directly in some cases it might be
directly but we think this would be
strongly influenced motor neurons and we
call that a motor message we normally
think of the branch going up to the
brain is carrying a sensory message
about the environment obtaining an
adjoining or skin indentation but
because of the nature of the branching
here this would also be an exact copy of
this motor message
and an exact copy of a murder message is
a definition of a difference copying now
one that point I want to emphasize is
that the message going up to the brain
is a single message it's a single
pattern of action potentials it can be I
analyzed by some set of postsynaptic
targets as a sensory message and by
others as an efference copy so the idea
that you have a single message that can
be analyzed differently shouldn't be a
problem that the the message can be
multiplexed in this way so why do I say
all that's what we go back to our
diagram here are driving inputs that are
innovating thalamus and this
informations related to cortex we now
know from anatomical studies from many
labs that most if not all of these axons
are branches and that tells us that the
message going being relayed through
thalamus is a copy of a message going
elsewhere and in many cases the extra
thalamic targets are motor centers I'll
give some examples of this these are
retinol axons taken from the cap the
they have branches innervate the lateral
geniculate the Kapiti can follow the
extra thymic branch to the midbrain
where it innervates the superior
colliculus and protect them every
quarter at little branch that we looked
at does this every retinal axon and
these are centers that we can interpret
as motor centers because the colliculus
controls eye movements the protectin
controls pupillary size focusing and so
on here's an early example from calling
there many of these in the early
literature he's showing the lamech
inputs from the deep cerebellar nuclei
to the motor thalamus and again he
emphasized that these are all branched
and the other branch goes to mid
brainstem structures that we can
identify as motor because they go to the
red nucleus the the which controls it's
a bobo spinal control nucleus for the
rubra spinal pathway this would be the
ridiculous final pathway
and there are a number of these examples
here's his prep the best one it's a
relatively recent paper by kita and kita
we looked at layer 5 cells in motor
cortex that are pyramidal tract which
means these axons actually enter into
the pyramidal the spinal cord and can
presume to have some fairly strong motor
effects multiple branching all over the
place they showed us a number of
examples like this all look the same
here's the thalamic gab branch and say
here's your trans lamech pathway but
this message is copied a copy of
messages to many other centers the one
this match is going to the spinal cord
as a motor message and there are other
centers that we can identify as boh boh
spinal control centers so these are all
examples of branching axons that are
involved to transmit pathway that seem
to be carrying a message that in some
cases is the copy of a motor message so
the sort of sum up the idea is that
information comes into thalamus from the
periphery through first order relay can
be sent to a primary cortical area and
then we can go through translates as
much as we want up a cortical hierarchy
but there are direct connections as well
and I raised the questions about this
one insight as to what's different
between these two pathways disease
direct connections with very rare
exceptions represent axons that have no
subcortical branches so this is
information stays entirely within cortex
whereas these pathways for the most part
have branches which means this
information is shared with other parts
of the neuraxis that's an anatomical
fact many of them are motor centers and
we're trying to make sense of that the
idea that there are events copies I'll
remind you is our speculation you don't
have to agree with that but I am drawing
attention to some anatomical facts that
that's our big for some experimental
testing okay so the final speculation
now has to do with comparing our view to
the conventional view conventionally the
ideas information comes in to the
elements from the periphery it goes to
sensory cortex it was up a hierarchy
through several stages of sensory motor
processing
finally gets to a high level of motor
planning on executive area where
messages sent out eventually to control
behavior and somewhere at the end of
this might be a single finally friends
copying now there's several challenges
we make to this one is it I would argue
that and this is all hand waving that
this makes no sense from what we think
we understand about evolution because
evolution who think does not produce a
new sensory receptor or sensory element
and without having a fairly immediate
behavioral effect our motor effect
because such a process wouldn't survive
evolution so the idea that evolution
would provide provide a circuit that
took so much processing before you get
any effect any benefit from it we don't
think makes much sense again that's pure
hand waving so the idea of a single
entry and an exit point for cortical
processing we don't think is sound from
a perspective of evolution this also has
no role for most of the elements that
we're calling higher-order the
alternative view does give us fairly
immediate motor potential motor effects
as the information is processed through
thalamus through these branches and as
the information it has more
computational power behind it we update
the motor command and that update that
message is sent through thalamus and up
the hierarchies that continues things I
want to emphasize is the thing the air v
dot puts are found from every cortical
area including primary sensory areas so
the idea that we have sensory and motor
cortex we're suggesting is an
oversimplification every cortical area
has
or output the differences between
sentiment recall sensory and motor is
more quantitative than qualitative
I'd also emphasized that cortex for all
of its beautiful computational power and
circuitry will be utterly useless except
for the fact of these layer 5 outputs
order that represent the only way in
which cortex can interact with other
parts of the central nervous system and
spinal cord to affect behavior without
these outputs there would be no effect
on behavior so it's important to
recognize that I think finally just to
remind you we have these direct
connections as well with lots of
questions that arise from that one
emphasized that if you want to send an e
friends copy between cortical areas you
don't have to pass it through thalamus
so the question remains why we use at
lemak relay for whatever this
information route is final point I want
to make is that evolution is messy one
way to look at the develop evolution of
difference copies is that from an early
vertebrate ancestor that operated mostly
on spinal circuits motor commands
involved in these spiders spinal
circuits would have had to have aprons
copies associated with them and I've
suggested one way of doing this but as
we developed as evolution produced more
flexible ways of controlling behavior
through Bobo spinal mechanisms a group
of spinal nucleus tech no spinal nucleus
and so on each time a new motor circuit
was evolved different coffees had to be
evolved along with it and the same
thought ultimately applies to cortex
so if cortex is going to produce an
output that creates a behavior where
we're asserting that there should be an
efference copy associated with that
however that e-prints copies produced
we're suggesting one possible anatomical
circuit for it but again that's a
speculation a problem that I don't think
is recognized is it as a result of
evolution we have different copies of
many levels hierarchical levels that
reflects evolution
that the brain has to sort out somehow I
don't I don't have any suggestion for
how does it but I want I want to suggest
that this is a problem that needs to be
addressed so to summarize what we're
saying is the cortical cortical
immediate communication appears to
depend heavily on higher-order flemeth
relays such as the pulvinar why does
quarter huh
why does quarter called cortical
communication seem to involve two
parallel pathways directly via thalamus
what's different about them
why is one sent through thalamus these
are still open questions how common is a
parallel organization of direct and
trans lemak pathways from cortical
function we have very few examples we'd
like to have many more to see how common
this says what is different about the
information content in each pathway why
is one process through thalamus and
finally what is the significance of the
branching axons
when it precise for the last time that
the branching axons do exist they are an
anatomical fact that is now pretty well
established for many labs be friends
copies ideas and I thrown out was just
our speculation you can accept the
reject that we hope to have ways of
testing these ideas and if they get
rejected fine but we do have to I think
to strive to get answers to why this
anatomical pattern seems to apply to our
dilemma cortical processing I'll leave
it there thank you
[Applause]
so I would just like to clarify
something and that one figure that you
keep showing over and over in the higher
order like the puppy now for example is
the different subdivisions that receive
input from different areas do they talk
to each other or not could you never
show this one in Thomas yeah there are
no connections that have ever been
identified between economic relay cells
so there's no the only communication has
ever been suggested for thalamus is you
can't go from a real a cell and thalamus
to the Flajnik reticular nucleus to
another relay cell but there are no
direct connections between polemic relay
cells so that would be inhibitory right
how do you fit the direct pathway from
cortex area 1 to 2 and into the driver
modulator framework so you said the
thalamus to cortex is a driver input
what about the quote and there's also
modular anklets from Alice - cortex -
how do you fit that one the budgetary
inputs do exist we haven't studied those
in the higher or two relays very much
the ones we've seen a banal driver
cortical cortical can be both and we
know in layer four for example that
you've got a driver input through the
translated pathway and the cortical
cortical can be either driver or
modulator depending on what layer cortex
they come from that's what we've been
finding so there is convergence and the
convergence is complicated depending on
the nature of the direct pathway and
what layer comes from how what that
means we don't know and that's that's
another reppin question
second no I can't but there one thing I
can tell you is that the latency
suggestions of latency of the two
pathways it doesn't lend itself to any
simple answer and the reason is if you
think of the visual system the direct
connections between v1 and v2 that are
representing central vision are very
short because of the topography if
they're representing an area of 15
degrees out there very long so the
latency should be short for central
vision and longer for peripheral vision
to go down and up is the same latency
for either of those and those are the
fastest conducting exons in the brain by
the way there's also a direct connection
between v1 and MT which is very long so
for example we would say that the
latency of the direct connection for
central vision is much faster than the
translate ik one the trans lamech one
between v1 and MT is much faster than
the direct one so I don't see any
obvious pattern there for calculations
are correct
when you open up in the whole animals or
yeah I should have emphasized that we
can do the calcium imaging only down to
the bottom of layer three so what you're
seeing or layers two and three we are
now using electrode arrays to see if
deeper layers are doing the same thing
it's a great question I forgot to
mention this so whether what we're
seeing in the upper layers reflects
what's going on in the lower layers are
still an open question open or people
that have there's a long history of
people doing in receptive fields in
pulvinar the complexity is all over the
map and part of the problem is that if
you put R gets an input from 30-some
visual areas each of which has their own
specializations for all they respond to
visual stimuli one conclusion you can
make is the complexity of seeing
pulvinar is consistent with the
complexity you would expect from layer
five inputs from all these areas
probably you don't know what areas
intervening particular pulvinar self so
the simplest parsimonious explanation is
of pulvinar cells like geniculate cells
are simply reflecting their layer five
inputs for the receptive fields whether
polar cells are are putting together
inputs from different cortical areas
there's an open question and I think
it's an important one
so the general rules for the branching
axons of you you focus this on sort of
sensory and motor areas as you get up
towards a prefrontal cortex in areas
like nucleus reunions TMD and so on do
you see the same sort of thing you seen
the branching this is an order data this
is this is data and there's a problem
with printing axons the data base is
pretty thin because it's very difficult
to demonstrate branching axons
you can do it by double labeling but if
you have a negative result means you may
have miss one of the areas you can do it
by a majority activation same problem
applies so the only to me the only good
way to do this is actually labeling the
entire act of the cell and the axial
annarbor the Contra Sagar just assign
your labeling there very few examples of
that because that's very difficult with
some striking to me is every example
that I can find in the literature where
that has been done in doing axons branch
and it's from multiple cortical areas
[Applause]